people will say do you keep a notebook
and the answer is I think a writer's
notebook is the best way in the world to
immortalize bad ideas my idea about a
good idea is one that sticks around and
sticks around and sticks around it's
like to me it's like if you were to put
bread crumbs in a strainer and shake it
which is what the passage of time is for
me it's like shaking a strainer all this
stuff that's not very big and not very
important just kind of dissolves and
falls out but the good stuff stays you
know the big pieces stay I had the idea
for under the dome when I was teaching
high school back in 1973 and it was just
too big for me and I was too young for
it and I wrote about 25 26 pages and put
it away
there's a scene at the beginning of this
book where this woodchuck gets cut in
half when this dome comes down over this
town I had written that part when I was
in in my early 20s and just sort of
recreated it from memory when I when I
wrote the book so the good stuff stays
so my thing is like usually when I'm in
my phone you know it's because you said
something you said something if someone
said something that's prompted me to be
like oh I got to write that down doesn't
have to rhyme you know right away it
doesn't have to be you know a thought
you know it doesn't have to be a bar it
just can be like something you said like
even like I think the last thing I wrote
down was like someone last night was I'm
at feel like I've become a recluse and I
was like man recluse that's such a great
word I love that works right now I write
down like use the word recluse you know
right so if you hear recluse in the rap
it's because someone said someone said
it right so that's just like those type
of things I mean I keep a constant
notepad of just ideas play by play if
you read through that notepad you can
really see where my mind is out where my
life is at but no one is allowed to read
through that okay my intention with this
video was to spread understanding not
fighting I want you to see that it's not
one point of view or the
you can pull and learn from both
especially the one that you don't
immediately resonate with embrace the
genius of the end